Other people can learn from writer's
life many things because La la writers'
lives are so different.
Some are processed.
It's something that comes from outside.
Some our process with their visions
likes of me are different.
I work like a cloak and then also my
books are more like frescoes and epic,
so I start from a corner and continue
and continue without even knowing what
the final picture will be in the end.
40 years of devotion to the art of the
novel taught me one thing that is to pay
attention to people's lives,
to pay attention.
What you wrote here about people's lives
this now as strange as in my mind is
based on interviews that I did with lots
of people that that also taught me to be
modest about people's life and play
around with the details of their lives
til it really sounds more real than
reality.
Most of my life,
I did not have a proper editor since I
was writing in Istanbul.
I am my own editor,
but the secret of writing is the right
thing.
Self editing,
editing,
leading to your beloved ones,
to your wife,
to your daughter.
To Your partner and hearing the story
from other people's point of view.
Never giving up your high standard of
criteria of good writing,
but continuing on and on and on and on,
and editing and editing and care taking
out,
no matter how much time you gave to that
beautiful page,
perhaps that can also be cut out.